hey 42 here some photos can tell rich
detailed stories or worsens five a
thousand questions and cause a most
benign of minds to race with intrigue
such happened when this photograph went
viral on the internet after it
resurfaced in 2011 it's not a new
photograph by any means taken in 1935 it
has been wilded many and unlocked for
generations it seemingly depicts a brave
solitary man refusing to salute Hitler
during his speech announced that it
noticed that the time would surely bring
horrendous punishment upon him
people have longest who is that man
Walter who drives him to risk his life
and being so defiant
I mean it's evident by the gentleman's
body language that he didn't just forget
to Heil Hitler
he's out to cause trouble this badass
was German shipyard worker August lund
Messer and all ghosts brave act of
disobedience who is born out of love now
you had better prepare yourself because
we're about to embark on a love story
that makes the notebook look like a
Twilight fan of it flashback to 1931
Germany's economy is in tatters your
family can't afford a sauerkraut
sandwich between them Hitler's rise to
power is just getting going
handing out flyers saying come to our
Nazi rally Friday night there's free
beer all round do bring a friend as long
as they're German so what does August do
well if he joins the Nazi Party of
course in hope of a better job
three years later he met his forbidden
love a Jewish woman named Irma Eckler
just a year after they got engaged
because of this August was expelled from
the Nazi Party the betrothed couple were
registered to be married in Hamburg but
a month later the nuremberg laws were
enacted which made their union illegal a
few months later they had a baby girl
named Ingrid and then the famous photo
was taken soon after when Hitler
unveiled a new military vessel at the
shipyard where will gust worked his
crushed arms steely gaze directly into
the face of the Fuhrer himself Oh
expression of his anger twas the way his
wife child and he had been treated by
the political party that he hoped would
help him but I'm afraid this isn't a
love story with a happy ending things
only got worse for poor Gosselin Messer
and his family earner fell pregnant
again and feeling what would happen to
their family August
Irma and baby Ingrid attempted to flee
to Denmark but sadly they were
apprehended at the border or ghost was
charged for dishonouring the race and
imprisoned for a short time the Gestapo
ordered or Gloucester have no further
relations with Irma obviously he
disobeyed their orders and only a few
months later was arrested again and
sentenced to two years at a
concentration camp at the same time the
Gestapo seized her and sent her to
various concentration camps over the
next few years where their second child
would be born August would never see him
again she eventually met her end in the
gas chambers at bernburg the two
children were sent to orphanages and
went into hiding several times until the
end of war luckily for them they
survived but our poor protagonists or
gospel and Messer wasn't so lucky
after his fan in the concentration camp
came to an end he was drafted into a
penal battalion and ordered to fight in
Croatia against the Allies peanut
battalions were basically poorly armed
and poorly trained units assembled from
German prisoners of war and forced to
fight for the Germans and what were
often suicide missions August was killed
in action in Croatia in October 1944 but
August legacy will never die for the
photograph which captured his bravest
moment will live on for eternity
inspiring thousands more to fight
against seemingly unstoppable evils if
you want to make a difference you have
to be the difference thanks for watching